schlag gegen die kriminalität in
nordrhein westfalen in den frühen
morgenstunden durchsuchten beamte des
landeskriminalamtes sowie die polizei
elf wohnungen und firmen in den städten
wuppertal solingen essen bielefeld und
düsseldorf
im visier der fahnder ein türkisch
arabisch stämmiger familien-clan wir
haben hier heute insgesamt vier männer
festgenommen die im verdacht stehen
einen erpresserischen menschenraub also
einführung eines mannes begangen zu
haben
hinzu kommt noch der verdacht der
gefährlichen körperverletzung und des
betruges
also die täter sind alle der polizei
hinreichend bekannt
da der besitz von schusswaffen nicht
ausgeschlossen werden konnte übernahm
spezialeinheiten die festnahme der
männer
auslöser für die razzia war die
entführung eines autohändlers aus den
niederlanden
der mann wollte den beschuldigten ein
angeblich hochwertiges auto abkaufen er
wurde dann jedoch um seine anzahlung
geprellt und gewaltsam nach solingen
verschleppt wo die männer versuchten
weiteres geld vom niederländer zu
erpressen
auch nach der razzia und den
verhaftungen dauern die ermittlungen an
also derzeit kann man hinter mir sehen
das natürlich die durchsuchungsmaßnahmen
noch im vollen gang laufe wir haben
unter anderem auch noch spürhunde die im
moment im einsatz sind
grund dafür ist natürlich dass wir uns
erhoffen noch weitere beweismittel
datenträger und vermögensgegenständen
die hier sicherstellen zu können